Okay, the answers of these questions are that the
trade is sex-linked with regards to its inheritance pattern and
it appears to be recessive. Now how do we know
this? Well, as fas as inheritance pattern is concerned, it
looks sex-linked, because only males are affected. That's a
hallmark sign that we have a gene traveling on an
X chromosome somewhere. It can't be maternal inheritance because maternal
inheritance means that it's passed down through the mitochondria and
so if a mother was affected all of her children
would be affected. And in this case we have an
affected son who doesn't have an affected mother, so that
can't be right. Now while it's still plausible that it might
be autosomal. The big skewing here of only males being
affected is our big hint that it's most likely sex-linked.
In reality, we'd really need a pedigree that's bigger than
this. We'd need more information, but for our intents and purposes
here, this is the sort of size of pedigree
we're looking at, and this is a good enough
indication that it's more likely sex-linked than autosomal. The
trait also appears to be recessive, not dominant. Because
it doesn't show up in every generation, which is
a hallmark of recessive traits. And we have unaffected
parents giving rise to affected offspring. And dominant traits,
we see the opposite. Where affected parents have affected offspring.
And it doesn't skip generations. So we
know dominant's most likely not the right answer.